good afternoon good evening good luck my
name is Matt Welch I'm the
editor-in-chief of Reason magazine here
on reason TV we are in denver colorado
covering the Democratic National
Convention which begins today just a
couple of hours earlier at the whatever
they're calling the arena these days i'm
here with reasons political dream team
to my right we have government affairs
director mike flynn to my left our crack
political reporter and columnist
associate editor Dave idle and to his
left we have contributing editor and
columnist to Reason magazine Tim
Kavanaugh and we're here to talk about
what we're going to be looking for as
this week unfolds of Hope tastic unity
and re-regulation and ending all war now
except for the war in Darfur which I saw
honest sign in a house about three
houses down hopefully we'll be launching
that soon we'll start with Dave Weigel
Dave you've been here all day looking
around threw me out what works and what
doesn't on what are you looking for this
week I'm looking for the level of
confidence and euphoria among Democrats
the the big story that i'm reading from
every other news organization reporter
is the division between clinton nights
and obama i'ts I haven't seen much of if
you dig for it it's there but there was
a march today of a Clinton nights that
could drew of 37 people if mostly
Democrats are like this we got this as
long as we don't screw up like we do all
the time like we've got Democratic
Senate House and presidency so I'm just
trying to find out what they would
goodies they want to come down out of
the cornucopia after this is over flem
you've been to quite a few Republican
conventions and Democrat Democratic
conventions but you've worked more let's
say in the Republican side of the aisle
and sometimes even as a lobbyist uh
what's wrong what what give your
starting what can you uh what can you
tell us about something that you
might into it from the proceedings
around here that the average Schmo
journalist wouldn't wouldn't know one
thing i'm going to be looking for
especially from the special interest
groups assigned to fear because for
months we've been looking at obama
coordination that it was a it was a it
was a foregone conclusion that you would
with in the last few weeks you starting
to see sorry indication to people
talking about this is actually going to
be a campaign this could actually be a
late night on election night how would
that manifest itself like that well you
know i mean there are you know and
interacting with people the other thing
i'm really looking for actually to be
honest because his reason is are the
parties because you know when the
democrats came into control of congress
they they had all this talk about
ethical standards we can make most
ethical Congress ever and they pass all
these gift rules and all these bands
well then in turn out that the gift
rules will severely impacted the
conventions and so several weeks ago
something was really not reported by the
news there were what a series of rule
reinterpretations just took a few weeks
ago just a few weeks ago they
reinterpreted the rules that would allow
a lot of these events that will be going
to throughout the week and so I want to
see how these events compared to past
conventions that there is actually any
real difference between them and I I
don't think there is a tall and I don't
care that there is I just care that
these people think seeing the thing that
did they feel that's right speaking of
events and parties we just learned that
Bruce Springsteen and jon bon jovi might
be playing at the final rally at Mile
High Stadium whatever they're calling
that these days another native son of
New Jersey is Tim Cavanaugh Tim what are
you looking for this week well I'm just
trying to convince everybody the
darkness on the edge of town is where it
all went south for the boss
since I now I'm wearing the nick
gillespie memorial leather jacket and as
such I feel right sort of represent
America on the way in here we spent
about 15 minutes in the Diamondback
state of Arizona where I saw one run
Paul signed and no John McCain sides so
I'm wondering what kind of campaign
since Mike mentioned it we will see
shaping up it has been a carnation for
Obama and you know I think McCain's best
card is that Americans hate hipsters and
that's where Obama has landed and you
know how house where can he make himself
over the next few days I think is going
to be a big question something about
anomaly has the Brooklyn vote so he's
trying to make himself square and it's
this convention is a lot more star and
stripe and spangled than various and
various patriotic colors they're trying
to turn his goofy store like they're
trying to return mr. 2000 2004 from the
weird saga of a kid who went lived in a
bunch of countries to the ultimate in a
Horatio Alger tale so this is a much
corny or convention thus far that I've
we handle this I find it fascinating
comes up that's where everyone's talking
about elitism and arugula and all these
kind of things when Obama stories you
mentioned is more it's aspirational it's
the it's the kid who done good and went
to college and all the stuff Wars McCain
comes from a family that had already
aspired before him and he both was born
into and married into wealth and yet
Americans perceive him to be much less
elitist and those dynamics gonna be
really interesting to play on as the
week goes on well with that we'll be
giving you a more crack analysis like
this as the week goes on and taking some
video footage which we already started
in the last couple of days and of course
getting back to you on the blog and
elsewhere for recent TV and for Mike
Flynn Dave Weigel and Tim Kavanaugh and
the unseen cameraman I am that Welsh
thank you and goodnight